في الحوزه العلميه والصديقان خامنئي ورئيس
ايران الاسبق رفس جاني حتى في سنوات سجن
خامنئي عاشت عائلته في منزل عائله صديقه
هذه العائله وامام التهديدات الحاليه
يحاول خامنئي اللجوء اليها لكن الصديقان
اصلا دبتا بينهما الخلافات اعترف بها
خامنئي وقت وفاه رفح جاني ويبدو ان ما
فعله خامنئي لا يزال حاضرا اذاكره عائله
نفسا جاني مهندس صعود الاول لمنصب المرشد
لكن حلم نفسانيه ببناء دوله منفتحه تحطم
عام 2013 لم يسمح له بالترشح للرئاسه
اليوم يحتاج لمن يعينه على اخماد حرك عصيا
على التوقف ويهدد به ايطاحه عرشنا
منذ ثلاثه واربعين عاما وهنا تظهر عائله
الصديق لكنها احترقت في الميدان وفي
الكواليس ايضا
فشلل مرشد باقناعي زعماء المعتدلين من
عائله رفس جاني والفضيني وحتى خاتمي
بمعركه احتراق الصوره ايضا من طرف اخر
وبيد الاشقاء ابنه الشقيقته لا تريد
التعامل مع نظام دموي
»
الاصلاحين والمعتدلين من الساحه السياسيه
مستغلا سلطته النافذه على مجلس صيانه
الدستور صفوه سجلت في انتخابات 2021 فوزي
رئيسي عكس توجهاته المتشدده ضيق المنافسه
بين المترشحين واخرج شخصيه يثق بها الشعب
من المعادلات السياسيه يدفع نظام وتحديدا
المرشده خطيئه بدات عام 89 حينما قال انا
لا استحق هذا المنصب كان ذلك قبل
الاحتجاجات اما الان منصبه الذي ظن انه
للابد مهدد